Stars, galaxies, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace, man over wings.
Liberty is such a wandering thing, behind us all come see, come take your place, we're leaving soon for...
Where's our planet now? Maestro, too tired by the long trip?
Feel quite well.
Connoissance report that there is a pre-Incan civilization here, well, miss that.
If it's true that there is such a civilization, can they join our confederation?
Admissions are welcome, but they are rare.
Yes, yes, we'll see, we'll see.
Just think pre-Incas, the Tiawanakans, the Nazcas perhaps.
That's very exciting, you know.
According to Piero's report, it's here.
This is our approach path for landing.
Is it true what you put in your report?
Well, we've all enjoyed ourselves so far. Now the situation gets serious.
Why did you instruct us to land so far away?
Well, I thought it'd be too difficult.
The area is studded with messes and butts.
butts high cliffs everywhere i thought it best to avoid the dangers strictly regulations all the
same it's curious to see a desert like this it's all wrong for the climatic conditions prevailing
what does our geologist think quite right maestro you wouldn't expect a desert here
island the peaks and this is their city wabamba to us too much honor gentlemen fellows they think
that we're gods this is our palace superb no superb a storage building this one contains our entire
stock of dried fish that building contains dried kelp and seaweed we keep records of the quantities
by using this kim fu.
Present, they have 13 tons in reserves,
approximately 30 kilos per inhabitant,
which they distribute when there is a food shortage.
The same is true in all their regions.
Calculations verified or correct.
Interesting, quite, quite interesting.
I assure you, this man is extraordinary.
He knows everything, even speaks our language.
He showed me some stone carvings.
It's incredible.
Our friend Chaco took us to see them.
Chaco will be a great chief.
You know, this fellow is extraordinary.
Metro, he learned all kinds of things, and in short time.
Males fighting for leadership of the group.
Bravo!
This combat might go on for several days.
But we have much way to go. We must leave.
E-O! E-O! E-O! E-O! E-O! E-O!
Soon, a new bridge will be here. It is almost ready. One big, big bridge.
Don't believe it. These people know how to do everything.
One thing they don't know how to do is take rocks out of the path. Oh well.
Llamas carry our gold, and they take it into our city.
Gold? Wow, now that's really getting interesting.
We pan gold down there in the street.
Best river full of gold here.
You see these women?
They are making our favorite drink, chicha.
Another kipu, yellow cord for gold, black for time passing, and red for harvests.
Coming along, they do those two down there.
Maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe I'm wrong, but it looks like they're weaving dried fibers into ropes down there.
Nine strands.
Three times nine, that's 27.
Three times twenty-seven, that's eighty-one.
A superb job. What workman?
Purely and simply magnificent.
M-m-magnificent.
Eighty-one ropes, drawn together into one, you realize?
As long as that, well, they weigh tons.
And did you see with what ease they managed all that?
Well, it's just extraordinary, the weight to lift the feet.
It's an engineering feet. It's over fifty tons.
We've never done better with simple means. Never.
Only one word for it. Genius.
Get men work. You watch them.
They are part of an iLoo.
It means a group, a social unit.
They live together and share the land and its products.
They share all their animals.
Each Indian belongs to an island.
These subgroups make up the larger agricultural community
ruled by a chief who collects taxes and pays a higher chief.
And that chief has ten subchiefs below him and so on up.
This decimal system of hierarchical chiefs rises to a power melt chief.
Oh, now that is indeed a brilliant idea.
Wise yucca.
Once again, visitors have come here to see us.
It is good, very good.
Honorable visitors, pray tell us what you think of our way of life.
Your society is magnificent, exactly as depicted in all the accounts of prehistory on the Earth.
It is an Indian civilization in the year 1000. For a student of history like myself, it's extraordinary.
It's all based on a simple principle, a decimal system of authority rising like a pyramid.
Other systems may have been found, but worse systems as well.
Do you know any that are better?
Of course, but that's a very long story. In any case, these days it's the best we can do.
Men are not ready. Technology any more advanced would end in great wars and destruction.
There is true rare wisdom.
Tell me, before landing our spacecraft, we flew over vast deserts.
Now, as I see it, that is, as we see it,
nothing in the geological atmospheric nature of your land explains its existence.
Why is it there?
Always return to that one question.
Why is the desert there?
One day, a very long time ago, in the sky, there was a battle.
Gods, the sons of light and darkness.
gods fell to our land. Their knowledge, science, whole universe. Then they set to work, building
their dwellings, which they wanted to make invulnerable, deep in the rock. Couched in
the hill like that, their fortress was a stronghold that no weapon trait, protected by a thick
layer of rock. They were true atomic shelters. They stopped gazing into the sky as if fearing
its anger. Much later, they grew less wary. Indeed, one fine day they came out of their
cave they were very pale from their long stay away from the sun and had long beards they founded
our empire they were good to us under their guidance our people great prosperity learned to
do everything opened hearts and brains to mend them the picture magazines of that time did you
hear what he said he he said that before it's extraordinary when you think that all that must
have happened so long ago yes millions of years ago oh the selfishness the envy in all men's
hearts is the scourge of mankind among our people some chiefs were jealous of their day they assailed
the gods trying to steal their secrets the gods rose back into the sky paired their spaceship they
were in a colossal anger as they left they threw down upon us a great sun that exploded turning our
fertile valley desert of dust and sand that is the answer to your since we have worshipped the sun
taken its proper place in the sky and we pray to it never to come back devastate our lands
subjects are treasures of higher can melt silver and gold these bellows are the largest most
powerful ever built all this running are messengers the chaski have they come far yes they run in
relays they can cover 1 000 kilometers in less than three days news isn't too good itas have
started marching this way the itas are people in the north powerful warlike hungry for conquest
But here, they are peaceful. They hate war. They have even forgotten how to wage war.
And the chief is afraid the defensive fortifications to protect the capital and the settlements will not be ready in time.
Speed it up, will ya?
I'll speed it up.
Itas are dangerous.
The chief fears that the fortress will not be ready in time because the Itas are advancing too fast.
What can we do for them?
It will be good if your guards come to help my people now.
I gather they mean they would like us to use our high technology capability.
Put us in a difficult position. This is a sort of interference. It doesn't conform to regulations we'd like to help, but we are not allowed to interfere unless it concerns Omega directly.
Any exception can only serve to prove the rule of mathematical certainty.
After all, it's a matter of defense, not of aggression.
Hmm. I see several of you hold definite opinions. And you, Lieutenant?
Well, insofar as we would act only in a defensive capacity, taking no active part.
Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Come on! Act! Do I have to repeat it?
Come on, must you repeat it?
Shut up!
Yes, Chief.
Bit more.
No sign, cosign.
A 15, carry the 1, carry this block, carry on.
Will you deliver this?
Deliver this message or it's the scrap heap.
Messenger boy now?
The highest achievement of modern science, the flower of technology, perfect in every detail, a messenger boy scrap heap.
Make a stare and attack.
Just has to be on top of our wall in a minute.
Look!
Inclusions!
I don't get over it in no time at all.
Take me more than five minutes.
Too close, it's dangerous.
Hey, all of you, out of the way!
Advice and training our warriors aren't up to the job, why?
Sacrifice the lives of our braves, et cetera, et cetera.
Why sacrifice the lives of our braves, et cetera?
With the help of our powerful friends from the sky, victory is within our grasp.
What you are asking is clearly against all of our regulations.
They are refusing to take part in any fight.
Well, then, why don't you just lend us your weapons?
That way you're not displaying orders.
I don't think you understand.
It's not a question of form.
It is a question of principle.
Come on, all we're asking is--
No, no.
I regret that it is out of the question.
Do not continue to embarrass our guests.
We understand your reasons.
We thank you again for your friendship.
Is there any reason for us to stay here?
Yes, because if we go now, we won't have solved our problem.
Civilization so rich in tradition, so artistic.
Yes, and in conflict, which makes them just like everyone else.
Thank you.
Is that you?
What happened?
We were too trusting.
They drugged us and took away our weapons.
Well, what are we going to do now?
I don't know, Commander, but we do it quickly. Those toys are dangerous.
Roll over this way. The first thing is to free ourselves. Let's go.
Take time.
The one thing we haven't got is time. They'll use our lasers.
They're like little children, immature, don't know what they're doing.
With those weapons, they're playing with fire.
Oh, I can't get through them.
The door's open. You may all come out.
The cards.
Turn to dust now. Don't school me. I had no choice. You'll see for yourselves.
Quick, free our hands.
Compared to us, a sausage is free as a bird.
Tell us what happened.
Well, you were all terribly sleepy after dinner.
I didn't understand a thing.
You dropped like flies, if I may so put it.
That moment, who should walk in but that horrible macho and his friend?
Gleefully rubbing their hands.
Once I saw it had been a trap.
They took away your weapons.
You should have seen how happy they were.
They tied you up.
Little Nabo played games with you.
As they were taking you away, they spotted me.
As they closed in, it was time to leave.
I waited for the right moment.
And here I am.
You're a good friend.
We can count on you.
Good work. Now we can get started.
You know where our weapons are now?
In the palace.
Quetzko was also taken prisoner.
Palace revolution. Let's go.
Yeah, and that one, does he go on dreaming?
Yes, it's better, but free his hands.
Then she said, whoo!
Use a little oiling.
Prisoner here in the cellar.
Yes, we understand your reasons, noble friends,
and we can only pray you to forgive us and pardon what some of us have done.
They will be punished according to our laws.
We implore forgiveness from the gods of the sky
and behoove them not to send us another sun that will explode and ruin our land as before
and which killed countless innocent victims.
Yes, that exploding sun mentioned in your history, in your mythology, but look here, we're not gods.
I insist, you must understand, we're only ourselves and we would never do such a thing.
Now I'm afraid that it's time that we leave you, but I sincerely hope that victory will be yours.
One day we will certainly return, and that day we're sure that your wise government and people
will be ready to join our great community.
It is difficult to thwart the vaulting
ambition of men at any time,
but we will try. My son would like
to have gone with you, but he cannot.
From now on, I will need him
here, my friends.
May the sun god speed you
on your way.
It's a wonder